[Music]
so time then for the Press previews our
first look at tomorrow's front pages and
tonight we'll be taking a look at the
papers with journalists and author
Christina Patterson and the editor of
the Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons
uh very good evening to both of you
let's have a look at the front pages
then before we discuss them nursing
Union Chief in Utah the pay deal is the
lead in the Sunday Times which says the
leader at the Royal College of Nursing
is now demanding a double-digit pay rise
for her members a change from her
previous stance and the patients now
face the threat of more strikes
the Sunday Express leads with a promise
from prime minister Rishi sunak that he
won't give in to pressure from the
Archbishop of Canterbury and others and
we'll go ahead with a plan to house
illegal migrants on barges while their
Asylum applications are processed
the people has a story about former PM
Boris Johnson paying 3.8 million pounds
in cash for a house which apparently has
a moat the telegraph meanwhile reports
that labor will give the vote to
millions of EU citizens if it wins the
next general election
the site of the Princess of Wales
playing the piano for Eurovision in
support of Ukraine is the main story for
the mail on Sunday in fact that pitch
won most of the front pages the mirror
reports that I'm a celebrity star Dean
Gaffney is being treated for bowel
cancer and if your eyes can take it to
start on Sunday as a picture of former X
Factor star Wagner playing the Bongos in
the buff
well let's not linger on that and a
reminder you can scan the QR code that
you see on screen join the program check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us discussing them to do
just that Christina and Jake uh right
let's get cracking let's start with the
Sunday Express shall we Christina
rishi's vow I won't budge my producer
suggesting a better headline would have
been PM won't budge over barge and just
explain what this round's all about
well this is about at um the Archbishop
of Canterbury has criticized the Tory
plan to hold migrants who come across
the channel on the small boats on what
they're calling barges I mean whether
they're actual barges I'm not sure but
basically not in fancy hotels and
um Justin Welby thinks this is
uncompassionate I think he is opposed to
the entire policy
um and Richie sunak is saying I'm going
to stand firm not least because it's
very important for the right wing of his
party that
um well and also he has said he will
solve the small boat prices which one
could argue was a slightly Reckless
promise since it seems rather unlikely I
have to admit I'm torn on this because
um I think the I think the Rwanda policy
is cruel and I think that it they are
you know the toys are saying you know
it's illegal where they are not offering
any legal routes for most refugees if
they if they stop this they're offering
no legal routes for the vast majority of
the world's refugees including people
caught up in the war in Sudan at the
moment and that is just not acceptable
on the other hand I have to say the cost
to the British taxpayer for um illegal
migrants they are those who are not
refugees to be put up in hotels is
enormous so I do think you know there
has to be a better solution than this
but I understand why for political
reasons Rishi sunak has to appear to
stand firm Jake Christina outlining
outlining the arguments there what's
your stance
well I think first of all it's important
to note the background to this which is
the Tory Wars uh that we've had this
weekend the conservative Democratic
organization this new organization
that's come over to Britain the
conference in uh in Bournemouth which
has been dubs to bring back Boris
conference with speakers like pretty
Patel and Nadine dory's calling for more
support for Boris and for him to be
brought back and so in that context
Rishi sunak has given an interview to
the Sunday Express where he's really
trying to burnish his right-wing
credentials by opposing the Archbishop
of Canterbury on this Flagship uh policy
of of deporting migrants to Rwanda now
in terms of how I feel about it I think
that the important thing is to stop the
boats I I don't agree with Christina
that there's no legal roots for Asylum
Seekers to come in to to Britain there
are there's lots and lots of people from
Hong Kong here lots lots of ukrainians
and Afghans and others syrians who've
all managed to get legal uh asylum in
Britain I agree with Christian that it
could be improved it could be made more
clear to people around the world in
Sudan and elsewhere and it could be
streamlined and made easier but those
roots do exist we do have a proud
tradition of accepting refugees in this
country but it can't be right for people
to die in the channel feeding this
horrible
illegal trade of people smuggling
um to try and turn up in in Britain
illegally and unfairly that has to be
stopped and it seems to me like the
Rwanda policy which is something that
the majority of Britain's support
um is a compassionate and right one
although I would like to see improved
roots for Asylum for legal Asylum
elsewhere okay um we're going to move up
we can keep talking about that all night
but we need to move on
um to get through some of these front
pages look in the mail on Sunday
um Kate on the front of all the papers
playing the piano and a surprise
appearance in in Eurovision she really
can't do any wrong
um Christina it seems at the moment but
zielinski not appearing
yeah I I mean you're right that Kate can
do no wrong and um she is multi-skilled
isn't she to play the piano like that
and look like that and and just appear
so poised and
um perfect all the time she's a very
salutary example and a slightly sobering
one for us all those of us who are
um not quite as skinny or uh brilliant
at piano playing or um you know all of
all the things I mean she is just if you
were to pick someone to be the spouse of
a future Monarch you couldn't really do
any better than that if you supported
such things but I Rishi sunak has
actually said that he thinks women's is
almost it was a mistake for Eurovision
not to allow solenski to speak at this
and I think that is right I think it is
a mistake I mean Ukraine the war in
Ukraine is the elephant in the room this
evening obviously the reason we are
hosting it when Ukraine won last year is
because it can't be held in Ukraine at
one of the hosts tonight is Ukrainian
Ukraine is a very central theme of the
whole thing it's not because Ukraine is
a lovely country that happens not to be
open at the moment it is because Putin
invaded Ukraine and has launched an
absolutely horrific war on on this
country and I think not to mention that
in this context is somewhat mad so I
disapprove I I think zelensky should
have been allowed to speak tonight okay
we're going to move on Jake we perhaps
ask you about that um in in uh in the
next hour but I just want to look at the
front of the Sunday Telegraph and we're
going to talk a bit about uh sakistan
and labor he's going to hand the vote to
millions of EU citizens if labor wins
the next general election uh the Sunday
Telegraph is revealing
yes worrying news I think um kirst armor
is is allegedly according to the sunny
Telegraph proposing to give the vote to
EU citizens who have settled status in
Britain but also give the vote to 16
year olds as well uh and those two
things alone would uh lock the Tories
out of power for a long time because the
younger people as we know are more
left-leaning as many of us know from our
own experience of the past
um and EU Nationals tend to be more
left-leaning because of brexit and
there's also the the sort of Specter as
well that if labor were to
um go into a parliament situation and to
form a coalition with the liberal
Democrats the price of that may be
proportional representation which would
then mean that the liberal Democrats
would be the king makers meaning that
that would end up with a left-wing
Coalition basically forever so it seems
to me a cynical move by kirst armor to
sacrifice the stability of our political
system uh in favor of rigging it so that
he can win more uh have more of a chance
of winning and potentially lock out the
Tories for a long long time and at the
same time I think that
um that system allowing him to have that
kind of Victory will be bad for the
country as a whole Christina
oh well the last 13 years have obviously
been completely wonderful for the
country as we can see from the state of
our public services and I think if
people live here and pay taxes here and
contribute to society then they should
be allowed to have a vote on what
happens in that Society I also think if
you can die for your country you should
be able to vote for um you should be
able to decide you know who's going to
be in power and finally I think that
proportional representation would be a
much much fairer system in so many
constituencies in the country in in
essence your vote is wasted because you
know that it's rigged in a bit because
of the the mathematics in a certain that
it falls in a certain way so I don't
think this is a cynical on Kia Stamos
part I think we should have proportional
representation and I'm all for it and I
think it it seems to me like uh
Telegraph paranoia actually to to call
this an anti-brexit thing we've had the
brexit vote as we know the vast majority
of people in this country now I think it
was a mistake but no nobody is
suggesting re-running that vote I wish
they would but they're not Jake do you
want to come in quickly I'll see you
shaking your head
yeah I just think that um to be in favor
of proportional representation is a
bizarre position if you look at other
countries that have proportional
representation it's awful Israel for
example at the moment which is going
through horrible political convulsions
is because of the instability that
proportional representation gives you it
allows you to bring Fringe parties into
positions of disproportionate power in
government it causes a lot of back room
sort of horse trading by the political
Elites out of sight of the electorate in
terms of forming coalitions that nobody
voted for and generally sort of tones
down the positions of different parties
in favor of something that nobody really
wanted so I think that arguing in favor
of that is very difficult particularly
given the fact that the last time we
were offered anything like that which
was the alternative vote referendum in
2014 70 of the electorate rejected it
it's not a popular policy in the country
and for very good reason indeed okay
just squeezing One More Story
politically related uh Christina it's in
the express the SMP leader saying the
labor party is identical to the tour is
vowing to continue campaigning for
Independence um this coming on the same
day that secure Starman made his big
speech
well I think he should talk to Jake and
I think Jake would quickly disabuse him
of that view and I think I mean and
frankly who cares what he thinks I'm
sorry but the SNP are a bastard flash
now and it looks as if labor are going
to win a fair number of seats back from
them maybe maybe even 15 in the next
election uh that would be good because
the SNP
um well and not just you know they've
done very badly for the NHS they've done
badly for the education system but also
they want to split Scotland away from
the UK which in my view would be a
disaster so given the scandals that have
happened in the SNP recently you
wouldn't expect the party to be uh doing
particularly well at the moment to be
but to be actually saying that the there
is no difference between
kirstama's labor and the Tories is an
utterly ridiculous thing to say and
doesn't bode well for their future if
that's what if you're a supporter okay
we're at the time for this part we'll
speak again in a moment because coming
up after the break we're going we're
going to take a look at this story it's
on the front of the Sunday Times nursing
Union Chief in a U-turn apparently over
a paid deal uh we'll talk about that
animal uh in a couple of minutes
[Music]
thank you
welcome back part to the Press preview
uh Jake and Christina are still with us
up front of the Sunday Times uh Jake
nursing Union Chief and you turn over
pay deal we know that the RCN uh
originally wanted 19 didn't they the
government then offered five percent and
a lump sum what's happening now
well the very bad news for for Britain
is that it looks like we're heading for
more nursing strikes
um already there have been 500 000
missed appointments and operations as a
result of the last lot of strikes or
lost various rounds of strikes
um which has had a serious impact on
people's health and well-being and their
lives and the lives of their loved ones
um and now uh the government offered
five percent Pat Cullen the General
Secretary of the royal uh of the RCA and
the Royal College of Nursing recommended
that her members accept that pay rise
and call off the strikes but the members
voted against and so she's come back to
demand new talks and done a U-turn
saying that she wants at least 10 pay
Rises and the thing is that if you look
at the the deal they were offered it
wasn't just five percent it was over two
Financial years with a one-off payment
as well of 655 pounds so overall cons on
a Consolidated basis it would amount to
nine percent and nine percent pay rise
so it's almost 10 percent and what
they're haunting is more it seems to me
a very thin reason indeed subject to
British people to further missed
appointments to real suffering in terms
of you know missed appointments and and
even more seriously missed operations as
well cancer intensive care they've
walked out of all of those things in the
past and I think it really is egregious
that they're continuing to strike
Christina
I think Pat Callan has messed this up
very badly I think to start off arguing
for 19 when everyone knew that was
completely unrealistic and then make a
recommendation and then when 14 other
unions have
accepted the government's deal then when
her own Union have said they don't want
to accept it she now says she made a
mistake and made a mistake and wants to
go back to the drawing board I think it
just I think she she just hasn't handled
this well and I think look I think most
of us have enormous Sympathy for the
nurses they had a terrible time during
the pandemic I think their pay has
fallen behind and I think in an Ideal
World they would be paid more but so
would many people so would most people
in fact very few people have had pay
rises in line with inflation in in the
recent years and the country thanks to
the Tories and brexit and of course also
the pandemic but largely I would say
Tory incompetence our economy is in a
really bad State and we just can't pay
above inflation pay Rises for huge
sectors of of the huge threes of the
public sector so I and I I agree with
Jake that I think more strikes would be
pretty disastrous a friend of mine had a
heart attack the other day on a day of a
nurse's strike and thank goodness you
know she survived but who knows it could
very easily be the case that there
wasn't enough care or or good enough
care available for in that day it's very
frightening time to to be old frail or
getting in a car or you know doing any
normal activity where you can have an
accident and I do think Pat Callan
really needs to talk to her members at
this conference and say look I'm sorry
these are not ideal times we need to
accept that the deal that we've been
offered okay let's move on to the story
in the Sunday Telegraph
um Liz truss is heading to Taiwan Jake
she's gonna be the first former prime
minister to visit Taiwan since Margaret
Thatcher and the 1990s
that's right I mean there is a sense it
seems in the Tory party that she's gone
slightly Rogue in going to visit Taiwan
in this way as if she was a cabinet
minister or a policy maker and she's not
anymore
um and it's a very very diplomatically
sensitive visit to make you know when uh
Nancy Pelosi the uh from America went
over there recently it sparked a lot of
saber rattling from China in terms of
military operations to threaten Taiwan
so it's a very very fragile situation I
happen to think that her position is the
right one I I share her hawkish
perspective on China I think that we
need to get real about China's creeping
dominance of the globe and the underhand
ways in which they seek to assert that
dominance or gain it
um I think her policy or her approach is
the right one but I think there's a
sense in Tory circles that she's rather
going off peace and going freelance here
um in fact in Tim Shipman's column
tomorrow he said that one source said to
him that she seems to think she's
indestructible he even though she's been
destroyed uh which sort of hit home with
yeah it was still major wasn't it
Christina that said when the curtain
Falls it's time to leave the stage
um she doesn't seem to necessarily have
heard that quote
I think perhaps you should be put in a
straight jacket of some kind I mean she
did her very best to wreck the economy
and people are still paying a price for
that now and now she seems determined to
get us all burnt to a frazzle in a
nuclear war of course China is not
Mother Teresa and uh we should be very
alarmed by all kinds of things it's
doing but making trips to Taiwan and um
and you know constantly talking about
Freedom as if as if these things were
straightforward it's a very dangerous
thing to do it's naive it's dangerous
and it's it's deeply unhelpful to
diplomatic relations there are channels
for these things she you know you do
them if when with the authorization of a
prime minister as foreign secretary or
when you're prime minister if not you
leave well alone and I mean I think Liz
truss because she's not just gone Rogue
I think she she this is really dangerous
stuff and I think somebody really needs
to tell her to get a grip okay uh
Christina Jake thank you very much we'll
leave you to catch up on Eurovision
schools and we'll speak to you again in
half an hour